it's a great pleasure to just quickly
introduce this university lectures Sean
Sullivan who of course is the director
of the Earth Institute I'm sorry the
lamont-doherty and and I just want to
say as I said just a few things first of
all the university lecture I mean this
is something that is really I it's the
ideal of what the university is all
about we come we listen to each other
and we're fortunate to have such very
very distinguished faculty who know
extremely interesting things and that
certainly is true of tonight so for this
decades-old institution we should always
be thankful the second thing is that
really proud of lamont-doherty and this
is a gem within the in within the
university and within the broader world
for the study of the earth and all the
things that happen out there are part of
what we want to bring to the bigger
world and that has done through a
variety of ways but not least through
the Earth Institute so lamont-doherty is
a gem and the third thing is to thank
sean for this lecture but for being here
every place I go people speak the
highest possible terms about his work
and about him as a person at of course
he has very very great honors including
the National Medal of Science and we are
really thrilled to have you here John
and very pleased to have this lecture
John coatsworth and provost
good evening it's my great pleasure to
introduce tonight's speaker Sean
Sullivan pardon director of the
lamont-doherty Earth Observatory
Associate Director for Earth System
science of the Earth Institute and the
William B Ransford professor of earth
and planetary science here at Columbia
this evening professor Solomon will
discuss the messenger mission mission to
mercury at which he is principal
investigator and help us to investigate
a consequential question why we explore
the solar system I had thought as we
were discussing earlier that he was
devoting his life to this project in
order to provide academic administrators
a very fast way to get out of town and a
distant address to hole up in but no
there he has a scientific purpose there
are few better suited to guide us
through a discussion of the meaning and
purpose of planetary exploration than
professor Solomon a world-renowned
scientists who have studied the
composition of the earth as well as what
lies beyond our atmosphere Sean Solomon
grew up in Los Angeles the child of two
New Yorkers as a budding scientist he
was first fascinated by dinosaurs and
imagined uncovering the mystery
mysteries of the Earth's past through
paleontology his interests shifted when
as an undergraduate student at the
California Institute of Technology in
1965 he watched a broadcast of
photographs from the Mariner 4 mission
that flew past Mars his course may have
changed but that desire to explore and
uncover the world's mysteries has
endured professor Solomon completed his
PhD in geophysics at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology where he then
taught and conducted research for almost
20 years at MIT he ran one of the
earliest ocean bottom seismometer labs
and its observations greatly enhanced
our understanding of the Earth's
tectonic plates
professor Solomon has led or been
involved in a number of space missions
to planets in the inner solar system
including the Magellan mission to Venus
the Mars Global Surveyor mission and the
Grail mission to the moon prior to
joining Columbia in 2012 professor
Solomon was a research scientist and
director of the Carnegie Institution in
Washington and there he also served on
the executive council of the nasa
astrobiology institute a body that seeks
to determine how life originated and
whether it might exist elsewhere in the
universe as I mentioned the rest of
Solomon is also primary investigator on
the mission jur the messenger mission to
mercury which has made revolutionary
contributions to our understanding of
the closest planet to our Sun in this
role professor Solomon is lead scientist
as well as director of all aspects of
the mission from its conception staffing
and funding to the final publication of
the results among its many discoveries
Messenger has confirmed and photographed
water ice on Mercury's poles something
scientists hope will lead to future
insights into how our solar system was
formed professor Solomon is a member of
both the national academy of sciences
and the american academy of arts and
sciences and last month President Obama
presented to him presented him with the
National Medal of Science the nation's
highest honor for scientific achievement
and leadership on colombia's palisades
campus professor Solomon is as likely to
be found in a seminar taking notes and
posing detailed questions to the speaker
as he is to be found behind his desk in
his office a dedicated advisor and
mentor his medic made it his priority to
ensure that the graduate students and
researchers at lamont-doherty have the
tools they need to succeed under his
leadership students and researchers are
making precisely the critical
observations and pioneering discoveries
that will shape our understanding of our
planet and ensure a sustainable and
resilient future for the earth and all
human life please join me in welcoming
tonight's University lecturer professor
on someone Thank You Lee and thank you
John I'm delighted to join you on a
rainy evening in New York City to talk a
little bit about why we explore the
solar system and in particular why other
than sending university administrators
we might wish to explore the planet
Mercury Wow one of the easiest answers i
can give for why i'm interested in
exploring the planets is this one that
we live on a planet that our planet is
four-and-a-half billion years old and
was born by processes that also led to
the formation of sister planets the
rocky inner planets Mercury Venus and
Mars the outcomes of the four
experiments in rocky planets are very
different and yet we know that the
starting conditions were more similar
the laws governing planetary evolution
should be common to all of the planets
and so I've always argued that to claim
that we understand our own planet
demands that we understand our planetary
neighbors and the reasons for the
different outcomes of the different
experiments in our solar system enters
we're learning from astronomers around
many other stars as well so to
understand what made our planet special
we really need to explore and and study
in depth other planets we could go to
the planet Mars one of our nearest
neighbors this is an image of course
from the Curiosity rover which filled
the pages of the science times today
this Rover has been on the surface of
Mars has since the summer of 2012 and
it's
exploring this giant mountain more than
five kilometres tall made of layered
sedimentary rocks in the middle of an
impact basin informally known as Mount
sharp Mars once had a more extensive
atmosphere when Mars once had water on
its surface running water possibly lakes
in the case of this impact crater and
elsewhere and is an illustration of how
an earth-like planet can start out with
more earth-like conditions and evolve to
a dry cold desert not unlike the Dry
Valleys of Antarctica we could go to our
nearest neighbor Venus which is the
closest to our own planet in terms of
mass it's got an atmosphere of mostly
carbon dioxide that's 90 times as
massive as that of the earth and its
experienced a runaway greenhouse and
climate change of the sort to dwarf
anything that we talked about on the
earth it has rocks that look like the
rocks of the earth and so far as we can
sense them it has huge volcanoes like
this one Matt Mons this is by the way a
false color rendering of a radar image
taken with an imaginary perspective and
a vertical exaggeration of 22 21 but
otherwise this is just like what it
would seem if you were on the surface
and it is quite possible that this
volcano in the areas around it are
volcanically active today on the basis
of measurements being made by european
space agency satellite in orbit around
Venus now and I think many of you have
followed the expiration of this comet
67p but again by the European Space
Agency and know that one of the reasons
we go to comets is because they are
remnants of the outermost solar system
they record some of the evidence for the
early
solidification of Isis and other
compounds that are easily removed at
high temperatures so-called volatile
compounds that occasionally you're
knocked into the inner solar system by a
passing body like this comet here and a
periodic comet and that four weeks ago
saw the European Space Agency plant the
first Lander on the surface of a comet
nucleus so those are all worthy and in
fact ongoing targets of exploration of
the solar system that would all help
inform our understanding of the origin
evolution of our own planet and why the
outcome of planetary evolution in the
case of Earth different from those of
its neighbors but we chose to go to the
planet Mercury almost 20 years ago in a
proposal to NASA and the argument we
made was in part the swap that Mars
Venus and by now comets have been the
subject of many many space missions and
this is a list just of the ones that
worked successfully and only two
spacecraft have been to Mercury and one
of those was in the 1970s in the second
one was ours and so simply on the
grounds that to go to a new place and to
make new measurements it provides more
opportunity for discovery and going to a
place that's been visited already by 35
spacecraft I think is one compelling
reason to consider a pivot to them
another of Earth's sister planets but
one that is comparatively unstudied but
there's are two good reasons why it took
more than 30 years between the first
spacecraft that flew by mercury and the
messenger mission which was the first to
orbit mercury and they're illustrated
here on this list it's hard to get into
orbit you have to slow down by a great
deal what the engineers called Delta V
amount of speed you have to reduce your
spacecraft and once you're there you're
close to the Sun and the day side
surface of mercury is extraordinarily
hot and those two aspects of the
environment must be dealt with by the
thermal design and so the challenge is
to engineer of slowing down at mercury
as you're approaching the Sun and
gaining speed and surviving that close
to the Sun kept any spacefaring
organization from mounting and Mercury
orbiter for decades the way we got to
mercury was quite complicated and it was
complicated to address the necessary
change in velocity and don't worry about
the details just appreciate this as a
complicated slide looking down on the
plane of Earth's orbit from the North
Pole of the celestial sphere you see
that messenger had to travel 15 times
around the Sun it had to fly by the
earth once Venus twice and Mercury three
times before at the guess I don't want
to use this because we can't show both
of these at once there's a timeline at
the bottom of the slide for those
looking here showing the time between
all those live bodies with propulsive
maneuvers in between each of the flybys
it was complicated but to try to picture
how complicated it was imagine that you
are playing billiards and you're
billiard table is three-dimensional
instead of two-dimensional and your
billiard table is about 200 million
miles across and you've got to shoot
your ball to within one part and 200
million or so probably half apart and
within 200 million six different times
in order to make it to your target at
the end and that's the challenge that
some very clever mission to
people have to face in order to use the
flybys of the inner planets to slow down
the trajectory of a spacecraft enough so
that it can be placed in orbit around
the innermost planet the rest of the
design of the messenger spacecraft was a
challenge to engineers and a triumph
really of engineering particularly
thermal engineering mechanical
engineering propulsion engineer and
communication engineering the spacecraft
had to be made extremely lightweight in
order that could be mostly propellant at
the time of launch it had to survive the
high temperatures near the Sun it had to
operate solar arrays of those high
temperatures and it had to operate in a
range of temperatures in Nightside of
mercury and that some of the elements of
the designer illustrated on on this
slide suffice it to say that the
engineers involved who were primarily at
the Johns Hopkins University Applied
Physics Laboratory rose to the occasion
it was it was really a life's
culminating moment for the thermal
engineers who've never had as
challenging mission as they did with
messenger to to come up with solutions
that satisfied all of the extreme
hazards and environments but let me turn
to the science because we went to
mercury to solve some questions and I
only have time to talk about three of
them but let me explain why these three
questions are interesting why they are
relevant to our own planet and why we
were able to make progress on answering
those questions from observations made
in orbit around the universe planet so
the first of the three it's what is the
composition of Mercury's surface what is
it made of we there were no measurements
of Mercury's surface material before
messenger we have no samples unlike Mars
and the moon we have no samples
this planet in our collection of
meteorites that there should be
meteorites from Mercury it's it's
energetically feasible but none have
been identified to date so the issue is
this we've known for many many decades
that mercury is the densest of the
planets when you correct for the effects
of internal compression of the effects
of pressure it's made out of the densest
material if you could compare it at
standard temperature and pressure and
the only element that's common in the
solar system and dense is iron so it has
been inferred for a long time that
mercury is mostly iron and the
presumption by analogy with the earth
and secondarily with Mars is that that
iron is in a central metallic core
inside mercury but it's a much higher
fraction of the planet than any other
and theoreticians have wrestled with the
question for years Wow as to why mercury
ended up so dense so metal rich and one
of these ideas is depicted in this
artist's rendition of a giant impact
that hit mercury a mercury that was
maybe the composition of Mars but the
impactor was almost the same size as
mercury and the result was to almost
disrupt the planet but remove three
orders of the silicate fraction ejected
into space where it was lost from
Mercury's orbit and leave behind a
planetary core and a thin shell of
silicate material there are other ideas
that are in the literature all of them
before our mission made predictions for
the chemistry what we'd see at mercury
service old classic hypothesis testing
classic scientific method in particular
all of them made this prediction on the
bottom line here that elements easily
removed at high temperature the
so-called volatile elements should be
depleted in mercury and by volatile
elements I mean alkali metals halogens
sulfur elements that are depleted in the
Earth's moon and were predicted to be
depleted in mercury so if we can measure
these elements we could test these
hypotheses so we took our two
instruments one was an x-ray
spectrometer and that just measures x
rays coming off the planet mercury
doesn't have much of an atmosphere the
Sun is a great source of x-rays the
x-rays that hit the planet in Iraq with
surface material the material
fluorescence and x-ray wavelengths you
measure the energy of the x-rays coming
off the planet you can determine the
composition of the atoms that are
fluorescent the second tool we use was
gamma-ray spectroscopy this is higher
energy photons than x-rays produced by
two processes one is the natural decay
of radioactive elements three of them
are sufficiently abundant to produce
gamma rays we can measure that's thorium
uranium and potassium but all of the
other many of the other elements produce
gamma rays through secondary reactions
with neutrons that are created as a
result of bombardment of mercury by
cosmic rays so cosmic rays generate a
cloud of neutrons around mercury and
many of those neutrons interact with
other atoms which then give off
diagnostic gamma rays so those are the
two to wonder why that it doesn't look
crisp from here anyway the very first
results now three years old on the major
rock forming elements magnesium aluminum
and calcium are shown here ratio to
silicon and what these results showed
you're looking at the red symbols are
for mercury the green symbols are from
the Earth's moon and the yellow symbols
are a variety of types of rocks from the
earth superficially mercury has a
heavily cratered service that looks a
lot like that at the moon but chemically
it is not at all like the moon and
compared with even the other major
planets including the earth
mercury is more more rich in magnesium
relative to silicon and poor and
aluminum and calcium compared with the
moon Mars and Earth so that's our first
measure that mercury something different
we've made a lot more measurements after
that all of these measurements by the
way were made from times when the Sun
was very active and producing energetic
x-rays and so we waited for more flares
to produce more x-rays and you see the
footprints on the surface of the planet
that allowed us to build up a larger
data set this is now fairly recent
compilation of similar data that all say
that's the same pattern mercury is not
the moon it's not the earth it's not
Mars in terms of major elements it is
similar to some rocks of the earth that
are high in magnesium fairly rare as
examples on the Earth's surface but
common on Mercury and now now we're even
mapping all of these quantities there's
a map of magnesium silicon showing you
that there are important variations some
of which can be correlated with
geological maps made on the basis of
morphological features about shapes and
superposition some are geochemical
boundaries that don't have obvious
geological boundaries so that that's
turning out to be interesting but here
are some some unusual results mercury
remember is mostly iron we know from the
mean density but iron is very rare at
the surface the surface abundance of
iron is one to two percent and that's
low by many multiples compared to the
other inner planets compared even to the
moon mercury has less iron at its
surface and more iron in its core than
any other body and so the ratio of iron
metal to iron in rock is much higher on
Mercury than on any other body and that
is satisfied by a condition that the
chemical that chemists call
chemical reduction that compared with
the other terrestrial planets mercury is
chemically more reduced than Earth and
Mars even in the moon hi and most of the
iron which is the most abundant element
is present in the most reduced form iron
metal but let's look at the volatiles
the very first surprise was this one
from the x-ray spectrometer this is a
map this is a plot of the abundance of
sulfur versus calcium and you know the
calcium is lower than in other
terrestrial plants but sulfur is high it
also seems to correlate with the calcium
but the sulfur abundance on mercury and
sulfur is one of those moderately
volatile elements that should be removed
by high temperatures sulfur is more
abundant on Mercury than on the earth by
a factor of about 10 all the theories
said it should be absent and there it is
there are more volatile elements that
are there an abundance greater than our
predicted this is a plot of potassium on
one axis versus thorium on the other it
comes out of the gamma ray spectrometer
both of these are radioactive elements
potassium's a moderately volatile
element and thorium is not and the ratio
potassium to thorium for Mars and the
earth falls along this line this is the
line for the moon these blue symbols and
Mercury's here in red on the same line
as the Earth and Mars so compared to the
other inner planets potassium this
moderately volatile element is in
proportion to thorium with the same
ratio that it is for Earth of Mars and
the moon which is known to be depleted
in volatile elements looks very
different so again in this element in
alkaline metal mercury d phi is the
predictions of the theories for how
mercury was assembled i'll show you just
one more plot this has not been
published and that's chlorine
chlorine is is a volatile element even
more volatile than potassium it's
plotted here on the vertical axis versus
potassium here and you see ratios as as
these lines of slope one this upper line
contains Mars and some meteorite classes
that are rich in volatile materials and
these blue symbols with error bars are
the measurements for mercury earth is
lower down with a lower chlorine
potassium ratio than Mars or these
meteorites so here again mercury is not
volatile deficient it has more of all of
this particular volatile or this ratio
of volatile than even the Earth's
surface materials so the theories are
not right it means that by whatever
processes the inner planets were
assembled it is possible to make a
planet that is both rich in iron metal
and not depleted in volatile and so
these this list of ideas here that there
was a giant impact that the solar nebula
was very hot and the vicinity of the
region where mercury assembled or
differentiated or that mercury was
preferentially produced by material that
was solid only at the highest
temperatures and that solar nebula can
all be rejected and we're back to the
drawing board on ideas for how the inner
planets were assembled in a way that
allows a mercury to be an outcome of
that process it does point to more
reduced starting conditions for the
material from which mercury was a symbol
than the other inner planet so we know
that there are some conditions in the
solar nebula that varied with position
but the theoreticians are now at work
attempting to reconcile these new
measurements with everything else we
know about the solar system let me talk
for a few minutes about the magnetic
field mercury the earth you probably
know has an
feeling I it's reason we can navigate
with compasses the magnetic field
generates a volume of space known as the
magnetosphere that shields the surface
of the planet from much of the dangerous
radiation that comes from the Sun that
comes from other parts of the galaxy
without the magnetic field this would be
a higher radiation environment one that
would be more of a challenge to the
origin and evolution of life Mars and
Venus do not have modern magnetic fields
but mariner 10 discovered that mercury
does that's a little odd because we
think the Earth's magnetic field arises
from convective motions in the fluid
outer iron-rich core by a process known
as the magnetic dynamo as a process that
converts rotational energy of a
convecting fluid into electromagnetic
energy and produces a sustained magnetic
field and we know a great deal about the
characteristics of the Earth's magnetic
field but what's key is that there be
some energy source to drive those
motions in the court and the court has
to stay fluid for the age of the planet
in order for there to be a magnetic
field today so mercury is a much smaller
planet than Earth but it has a modern
magnetic field and so we wanted to learn
enough about the magnetic field to try
to understand a little bit more about
its geometry and its history so the
geometry was a bit of a challenge the
field of mercury is weak it is an
earthlike field in its geometry but it's
weaker by a factor of a thousand by one
measure the dipole strengthened and it's
close to the Sun so that the volume of
space dominated by Mercury's magnetic
field is very small and what that means
is that there are current systems in
magnetospheres around planets and we
have them that the earth at mercury
those current systems are very close to
the plan
and so measuring the internal magnetic
field as a challenge to separate out the
fields associated with those external
currents and in particular you a lot of
the analysis techniques used for
planetary magnetism don't work but a
measurement is depicted here on these
slides that was a surprise we made
measurements of the location of the
magnetic equator from the position at
which the magnetic field attributable to
the planet interior was parallel to the
spin axis as it should be at the equator
and we did that for all orbits as a
function of longitude and you see the
first plots as the function of longitude
here so this is the geographica greater
at the bottom this is the position of
the magnetic equator this is longitude
on the horizontal axis and the answer is
that the magnetic equator is offset from
the geographic equator at all longitudes
by about 500 kilometers on this plot or
this plot and this is a small planet
that's about twenty percent of the
radius of the planet so this looks like
the Earth's magnetic field but unlike
the earth for the magnetic fields at the
center of the planet this magnetic field
is offset by twenty percent of the
radius toward them North Pole so it
looks like the field of a bar magnet the
so-called dipole the dipole points in
the same direction as the fields on the
earth toward the South Pole of the earth
it's aligned with the spin axis as the
Earth's field is if you average over
enough time but it's not at the center
of the planet it's offset and that means
that the field is is a symmetric about
the equator it's stronger at the North
Pole to the South it means that magnetic
field lines that are open to the
magnetosphere and the silver wind are
intersect the planet over larger area in
the south of the north we don't know
very much about the history of this
field up to now all we know is the field
that was measured by Mariner 10 which
visited 40 years ago and the field that
we can measure today and those are
indistinguishable so messenger has been
looking for the three and a half years
we've been in orbit for evidence of an
ancient field and Mars on the moon on
the earth the evidence of that ancient
field is found from rocks permanently
magnetized in the crust so we've been
looking for evidence of magnetic
anomalies in the cost of mercury and I'm
going to show you some new results that
no scientific audience outside of our
team has yet seen though that will
change next week before I do that I want
to say something about our orbit there
are two plots on here on this diagram
ignore the simple one and look at the
complicated when it is the distance that
the spacecraft is from the surface the
so-called periapsis altitude versus time
and time begins on the left about two
years ago and it stands over to the
right to next March and what you see is
that the distance of closest approach
gets lower and lower and lower with
every orbit except there are a few
places where the it jumps straight up
and that's where we have enough
propellant to fire our thrusters and
raise the altitude of closest approach
but we're running out of propellant I'll
come to that in a minute but notice that
the numbers here prior to last spring we
never got closer to the planet than 200
kilometres and prior to this summer we
never got closer than 100 but starting
this fall we got closer than 50 and we
got down as close to twenty-five twice--
and when we cross that distance of fifty
kilometers we suddenly saw something we
hadn't seen before we saw crustal
magnetic anomalies and what you see on
the top is a measurement of the magnetic
field magnitude and what you see in the
middle
plot is a residual after you correct for
the internal field after you correct for
the magnetospheric fields and after you
correct for the long-wavelength
component of the observations and what's
left is a shorter wavelength set of
anomalies these things here and what we
have shown is these anomalies persist
from orbit orbit here's the next orbit
and they're repeatable if we fly over
the same terrain as long as we're
substantially closer than about 50
kilometers to the surface and we can
begin to map them and compare them to
the geology and there are places that
have magnetic anomalies there are places
where we cannot measure a magnetic
anomaly but for the first time we are
looking at magnetized portions of the
crust dating back to a time when the
impact flux was very high maybe four
billion years ago and mercury has a
magnetic field and so we can conclude
several things we conclude that even
under the very reducing conditions that
mercury under which mercury was a simple
even given it's very low iron content it
has minerals that are capable of
permanent magnetization and that
magnetization was acquired encrusted as
much as four billion years old so it
changes our baseline for understanding
the history of the magnetic field from
40 years the time since Mariner 10 to 4
billion years so that's a factor of ten
to the eighth in an improvement in our
understanding let me close with a
discussion of Mercury's polar deposits
John alluded to that in the introduction
it's a story that is still continuing so
I'll show you some some brand new
results but it goes back 20 years to
earth-based radar which documented the
fact that there are deposits on Mercury
that look like water ice tuaw radar
system they reflect the radar waves they
depolarize the radar waves the same way
the water ice does
towles of Mars and on the icy satellites
of Jupiter and the reason that's not
crazy despite the fact that at the
equator of mercury the difference in
temperature between day and night is 600
degrees centigrade the reason is not
crazy is that Mercury's spin axis unlike
that of the earth has almost no tilt
it's perpendicular to its orbital plane
to within two minutes of arc which means
that an impact crater a hole on the
ground at the poles is in permanent
shadow there's not much atmosphere hole
in the ground is looking at at empty
space and it's extraordinarily cold cold
enough to preserve water ice so the
hypothesis going back 20 years was that
we would find water ice at the poles of
mercury but all we had with these radar
images so we took several experiments
that one by one helped us confirm this
20 year old hypothesis the first was
simply to ask are all the polar deposits
in areas of permanent shadow because
when the radar images were acquired we
hadn't seen more than half the surface
mariner 10 had only imaged forty-five
percent of the surface so we didn't know
whether all the radar deposits were in
impact craters much less in areas of
permanent shadow but we can make
systematic measurements of sunlight over
the course of a mercury solar day if
you're looking at the South Pole and a
sequence of images taken of just where
the sun is shining over the course of a
complete solar day I which on Mercury is
six months long and from that we can
make contour maps of how much Sun falls
on any given part of the south polar
region this is the south polar region in
all those black areas never see the Sun
and unlike planets like Mars the spin
axis mercury is stabilized by resonance
state between its eyes its spin its
rotation and its trips around the Sun
and as a result they spin axis is
extraordinarily stable and so if
something is impermanent shadow for six
months it's in permanent shadow for
three or four billion years so there's
those aryan in black are truly in
permanent shadow and we can compare them
with the areas that show up in the radar
images and they compare very well all of
the areas that are bright in the radar
images are in areas of permanent shadow
as documented directly by imaging of the
surface then there's a question of what
are the polar deposits made out of so we
took a neutron spectrometer with us on
the spacecraft specifically to answer
this question remember that the planet
is bathed in neutrons because they are
produced by cosmic rays but some
neutrons are absorbed by materials at
the surface and the best absorber of
neutrons over most energies is the
hydrogen atom and so the neutron flux
has long been used as a tool to look for
hydrogen or h2o in the case of water ice
and here you see measurements in red
this is an intermediate range of
neutrons compared against two models a
black model in which the polar deposits
have no water ice in a blue model in
which the polar deposits are pure water
ice and you see a good match to the blue
model the story is complicated because
we have also measures of higher energy
neutrons there are fewer of them the
error bars are larger but again the
black curve shows you what would happen
if the polar deposits had no water ice
for neutrons of this energy the blue
shows you what it would be if they were
pure water ice all the way to the
surface for neutrons of this energy and
the red data split the difference as you
go toward the pole toward the right so
the way to fit both kinds of data is to
say that the polar deposits are water
rust but that most in most locations
they're covered with a thin layer 20 30
centimeters thick of something that
doesn't have much high
and that's enough to slow down the fast
neutrons and not the intermediate energy
neutrons and explain both datasets we
had another instrument and that is the
laser altimeter that we use to do
measurements of topography but it's also
an active reflectometer and you see on
these slides a map of the average
reflectance of the surface at the
wavelength of the laser and foremost
there's an aryan gray where we didn't
look at first because the orbit of the
spacecraft didn't take us right over the
North Pole and so there's a cutout where
we had no data but in the rest of the
terrain the average reflectance is shown
kind of an yellow green and there's a
number there on the slide and the areas
where the polar deposits were seen with
based radar show up very dark there half
the reflectance of the average for
mercury which itself is very dark so
there is a signature and the reflectance
of the surface these are the areas where
the neutron spectrometer told us that
there's a cover 22 centimeters thick 20
to 30 centimeters thick of non-hydrogen
bearing material that material is very
dark it's darker than the rest of
mercury it is not mercury soil it is
something special and very dark then we
tilted our spacecraft and used our laser
to look at craters that were even
farther north then we're getting closer
and closer to the North Pole and what
you see in this plot to more complicated
is that there are places where the
reflectance is greater than the average
for the planet by factors of 3 or 4
mainly in the floor of that crater that
crater is called prokofiev and I want to
show you some brand new results that
were published just this month where we
took direct images of the permanently
shadowed region of the crater floor
sorry went the wrong way here's here's
the crater Prokofiev this area to the
south
is in permanent shadow but obviously an
impact crater and you can see a lot of
detail in the floor and this is itself a
mosaic of several images under different
lighting conditions the yellow shows you
where the bass braids are says the polar
deposits are located indeed they're in
areas of permanent shadow this is a
contour map of where the laser shows you
the high reflectance areas are and in
this particular plot we change the color
scale high as red so this area where
there are polar deposits is high in
reflectance in this crater not dark
under these conditions we opened our
broadest filter on our imaging system
made a long exposure image to look into
the areas of permanent shadow there is
no direct sunlight falling on the
surface in the areas of permanent shadow
but there is reflected light off the
crater walls and off the central peak
enough to see and what you see is this
and I draw your attention to this
boundary here between brighter terrain
here and darker terrain out here this is
within the area of permanent shadow it
coincides with the mapped areas of
permanent shadow more importantly it it
it has sharp boundaries it shows you
very small features including small
impact craters the reflectance of the
service doesn't change as you go across
these small craters some of which must
be very young to have survived and the
implication is that whatever is making
this surface very bright is young either
it was recently deposited or is steadily
deposited on top of surfaces containing
some very young creators it coincides
with the area rap mapped with radar
imaging so we're now building up images
of these craters with direct imaging at
visible wavelengths to combine with the
laser reflectance measurements of
reflectivity and the neutron
spectrometer
measurements to put it together a
picture of what we're looking at but
here's the hypothesis that in areas of
permanent shadow near the North Pole to
the left in this image these are places
where you can collect material that
impacts mercury in the form of a comet
or a volatile rich asteroid so this
cartoon imagines that a comet is
impacting the surface the combat is that
classically known as the dirty snowball
as described by Fred Whipple more than
half a century ago most of the ice but
with other material some of which is
dark some fraction of that material
after it is it is vaporized on impact
bounces around and Mercury's gravity
field finds its way to high latitude
craters where it is it is frozen in
place because these are some of the
coldest places on the planet but
remember that not all this crater is
equally cold and so the higher
temperature areas lose their ice and
more importantly they also lose this
dark material and we don't know what
this dark material is but we know it's a
volatile that is to say it is removed by
high temperatures it is removed only by
temperatures that are higher by 50 or 60
degrees then ice itself so that tells us
something specific about the material
but it is extraordinarily dark it is
among the darkest material in the solar
system and if it is delivered by comets
in the same manner that we think the ice
is delivering then the leading candidate
for this dark material is something
carbonaceous this dark material coats
all of these small solid objects of the
outer solar system where the amount of
reflected light coming off of these
objects is measured in a few percent you
can count it out on your fingers that
are spectrally red and their best
matched in the basis of laboratory
measurements with complex macromol
killer organic stuff tar Tolan it's a
fancy name and that material fits what
limited we know about this dark material
on Mercury it could be delivered by the
same objects that deliver water ice it
has the right reflectance and it would
be volatilized at about the right
temperatures but we have no direct
chemical measurements anyway by this
hypothesis further removal on under
temperature leads to what the
sedimentology Center is called a lag
deposit of dark material that except in
the coldest areas leaves this layer 20
30 centimeters thick a very dark
material overlying and thermally
protecting the underlying water ice so
the water ice shows up in radar it shows
up and reflectance measurements in the
few places that are extraordinarily cold
in the ISIS staple at the service and
the rest of the time the deposits look
very dark so let me wrap up by saying
that just asking these three questions
out of many we could have asked about
mercury has taught us a lot about the
innermost planet and something about a
row we learned that all of the models
proposed for how to make an earth-like
planet end up as metal rich as mercury
have to be cast aside because they they
made predictions in the proper
scientific method that were testable and
those tests have shown that the
predictions are not correct namely the
prediction was that mercury should be
depleted in elements as volatile sulfur
and potassium and chlorine it is not so
that changes our ideas for how the inner
planets were formed and we are still
awaiting a generalized theory for inner
planet formation that can account both
for the variations in major elements
among the planets and the variations in
volatile we've learned something about
Mercury's magnetic field the only other
example in the inner solar system beyond
Earth of a planet with a modern magnetic
field we learned the
you can have a magnetic field in an
otherwise earth-like core we think that
is very asymmetric about the equator
that does not look like the center
dipole that describes the Earth's modern
feel and has been assumed to describe
the Earth's magnetic field over its
entire history so what if the field we
see today at mercury describes some past
state of the Earth's magnetic field it
would mean that we would have to rethink
our interpretation of paleo magnetic
data on the earth and finally we've seen
this view of Mercury's polar deposits
first seen by earth-based radar 20 years
ago and hypothesized then to consist of
water ice and we assembled a suite of
instruments to test that hypothesis and
that hypothesis past the polar deposits
are indeed mostly water ice on the basis
of neutron spectrometry on the basis of
detailed thermal models that I didn't
describe here that make use of measure
topography on the basis of the permanent
shadowing on the basis of the reflection
measured in actively from lasers in the
coldest spots where water ice is
predicted to be stable right at the
surface but we discovered something new
that these deposits are covered not with
mercury soil to keep them cold but with
something different something darker
something volatile something possibly
carbonaceous so here we have an example
where the planet closest to the Sun the
planet that experiences the greatest
range in temperature from Dayton life
the planet where we least expected to
find it is a witness played for the
delivery of ice and probably organic
material from the outer solar system a
process probably that went on over the
whole history of the solar system that
may have contributed to the early
evolution of organic chemistry on our
own planet we're not recording all of
that history here on Mercury
seeing only the most recent tens of
millions of years but should we go back
with the right tools we could sample
this set of deposits is telling us about
how water and organic material were
delivered to the inner solar system
throughout the history of our own planet
I'm just going to close with this one
last still complicated slide to show you
what's ahead for the next four months
this is another one of these plots of
distance of closest approach to the plan
only this room only goes from next
January to next April and because of the
cleverness of our propulsion engineers
we have a little more propellant
remaining after our last scheduled
maneuver which was to have taken place
next January next month enough to do
what they call a set of hovering
maneuvers starting in march and
continuing for as much as two months
that will keep us as a planet rotates
underneath us in orbits where the
closest approaches about 15 kilometers
off the service we've never been that
close so we will be taking magnetic
field data we will be taking images at
unprecedent to chemical measurements on
the scale of geological units and it
really for the first time at that scale
so we hope to have a few more
discoveries in our pocket before the
Michigan anyway I hope you will agree
with me that there are reasons to
explore the solar system and to explore
mercury in particular and some of those
reasons do inform our understanding of
our own planet thank
we do have time for a few questions
there are microphones on both aisles so
you would like to ask the question of
professor Solomon he's ready to answer
and when we finished there will be a
reception to follow in your role invite
over here is it fair to say that there's
little evidence that mercury had a
global magma ocean that is that's the
first statement at some context for the
rest of you folks the late stages of
accretion of the inner planets are
energetic events where the there are
larger and larger impacting bodies as
the number of objects in the inner solar
system goes from a large number of small
objects to a much smaller number of
large objects and the leading idea for
the explanation leading idea to explain
the origin of Earth's moon is that earth
was hit by an impactor about the size of
Mars some tens of millions of years
after the formation of the earth that
was a major event in the history of the
earth it led to ejection of a lot of
material in Earth orbit some of that
material are created to form the moon
mercury ended up with a lot less
silicate than metal compared to the
other planets and so the question is
whether there was a giant impact that
was responsible for some of that if the
giant impact would have removed the
volatile I think one can reject that
idea the theoreticians who are looking
at giant impacts on Mercury Andrey
accretion of material are exploring
whether there are possibilities for
retaining enough of the volatile to
account for our measurement so I think
the jury's still out as to whether there
was a giant impact on mercury a giant
impact would have melted a substantial
fraction of the planet in the absence of
a high iron content we would not see the
evidence of a magma ocean in the crustal
composition that we see on the earth
moon so the absence of evidence is not
necessarily an argument for the absence
of the phenomenon but the way you cast
the the statement was was still correct
we don't know that there was a mag
motion but it's hard to disprove is it
possible to very roughly estimate the
expected comet impact rate on Mercury
and the expected volume of those ice
deposits to try and understand how much
ice we can expect comets in general to
deposit on a planet yes it is I don't
have those at in my frontal lobe but we
do know the population of comet orbits
we know that their orbit that there are
comets that pass inside the orbit of
mercury some of them are Sungrazers that
get to the upper atmosphere of the Sun a
few of you may have heard of ice on
which is a comment last year that got so
close to the Sun that it didn't survive
the passage but that was well inside the
orbit of mercury and by the way flew by
mercury close enough so we could take
data so there are comets that have a
range of orbits and one can calculate
based on the current population of
comets what the impact rate should be on
any solar system object all of the
periodic comets are thought to have
originated farther out in the solar
system have been kicked in by passage of
some
neighboring body and those kinds of
events are stochastic it's harder to go
back over all of solar system history
and know with with confidence with what
the rates are but to answer the question
implied by your actual question the
impact rates of comments on Mercury are
sufficient to supply over geologically
recent time the Apollo move water ice
that we see Sean Solomon thank you very
much for a wonderful evening if I can
say one more thing is that if we send a
university administrator on a quick trip
to escape the Earth's don't go to
mercury there are more happen more
hospitable places than that
new place and his